thank you
all right everybody Welcome we're
joining the day three of the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial
um in progress so let's get right to the
audio we'll have time during breaks to
catch up on other stuff right now the
detective who was on duty the night in
question is testifying it looks very
similar to one of the attorneys but it's
not it's two different people
can we now please play exhibit number 13
the Lakota licked Walt live stream
no boys
will we take one shortly but right now
okay go ahead
let's begin at the nine minute Mark Ryan
nine minute mark
twalties
now they're calling it day two because
day one was sort of jury selection that
this always happens whenever we cover a
trial but it's sort of day three overall
appreciate that uh the people joining my
uh joining my live stream from cjtv I do
appreciate it
um guys if I if I drop out again make
sure that you're jumping across to uh
Corey Elijah also another local here
who's been documenting things in our
hometown uh otherwise make sure you're
jumping on CJ TV uh and mercado media
does sound like we've got some stuff
going on over here I don't know if
that's
fireworks or what we have going on we're
gonna go try and check it out
to set the locations for the jury
Detective Howard we have seen this video
begin at a location and it appears that
the person taking the video is now
moving can you if you're able to can you
tell us where this person was at the
beginning of the video so at the
beginning of the video it appeared that
for the 12th was on the southwest corner
of Sheridan Road and 60th Street
the armored vehicles that he that you
saw in the beginning of the video were
at 60th Street now it appears he turned
the camera around and now he's facing
south
and as we watched this video is he
heading going to be heading south along
Sheridan Road yes okay please continue
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
can we rewind 10 seconds please
I want to call the jury's attention to
the center of Sheridan Road there it's
kind of in the center of the screen
right now there will be some figures
coming towards the camera I just want to
focus the jury's attention on that as we
start the playing again please
from there
was like one more frame
there okay
um
this individual who is running past the
uh videographer this individual here is
the defendant of Kyle Rittenhouse he is
headed back north of Sheridan Road while
this videographer passes him going south
go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
those are gunshots people
they're gunshots wow
[Applause]
I still don't know why the audio
completely cuts out at times from Court
TV I I have no idea why
myself
we've already seen this uh from a little
bit of a different angle but I'll
represent the jury and there's no
dispute about this the individual who's
crying out for a medic is Gage
grosskroix he's just been shot in the
right arm by the defendant this
individual who's just arrived who's got
the kind of greenish pants on that is
Jason lenkowski
right
here
let's maybe try a different feed that
might just be more conducive to what
we're trying to do here
Detective Howard can you describe for
the jury what's going on in that
sequence of events that we just saw
after Gage rose quartz was shot so those
are several armored vehicles from
different law enforcement agencies in
Wisconsin arriving to a report of shots
fired and they are attempting to render
Aid to victims but before they do that
they are concerned they because they're
not they don't know whether or not
they're still an active threat so they
come out with a show of force to secure
the area so that way after they secure
the area they can provide medical Aid to
the victims or the the people who got
shot the victims not allowed to say it I
know I've just presented a lot of videos
to the jury and I want your help
Detective Howard just so we can make
sure we've got everything in
chronological order based on what we've
just played for the jury and what you
know can you kind of describe the sweet
sequence of events uh in in the series
of shootings that we've just seen
starting with the the first shooting yes
so the the first shooting takes place at
the
63rd Street and Sheridan Road car Source
on the south end of our map here
that is where Mr Rittman house
shoots four times at Mr Rosenbaum all
right
so the first shooting with Mr Rosenbaum
and Mr Rittenhouse where four shots are
fired this takes place at the car Source
at 63rd Street and Sheridan Road at the
south end of our map that was after they
both ran in a Southwest Direction
going down to the left in this parking
lot
after those four shots are fired Mr
Rittenhouse
takes a direction Northbound he's on the
sidewalk briefly
and then he moves a little bit more to
the east
one of these closer to 62nd Street and
that approximate area he runs Northbound
on Sheridan Road in the middle of
Sheridan Road
at approximately
61st Street just north of that
intersection or right right at that
intersection that is where Mr
Rittenhouse falls down and takes a
position on his back
Southbound
the individual unidentified who attempts
to kick him
is shot at two times
and then Mr Huber was shot at one time
and then Mr gross Christ is shot at one
time and all of that takes place at this
location right here
and then can you just show us the
defendant's path as he walks away from
the scene after that after that Mr
Rittenhouse continues Northbound on
Sheridan Road
and the line of police cars and Bearcats
or armored vehicles originally was at
60th and Sheridan that's Sheridan and
60th right here and you mentioned
earlier there was a Kenosha police squad
car with officers Meridian Krieger in it
that the defendant approached can you
show us where that was on the map that
was that squad car was in the westbound
the westernmost Lane of southbound
Sheridan Road just south of 60th Street
so that KPD squad car would have been
right here
and then just for some
complete context here the original car
source that the defendant was at earlier
in the evening can you point that out
for us please
that was at Sheridan Road and 59th
Street of the southwest corner okay
thank you very much
we have seen a couple of versions of the
shooting of Mr Rosenbaum and immediately
prior to that he throws something at the
defendant have you seen that in the
videos yes was that item ever recovered
no
could we play uh exhibit number two
at the 253 Mark please
Detective Howard would you agree with me
that in this video we see
Center left Joseph Rosenbaum yes and in
his uh right hand is a plastic bag is
that correct yes
thank you
Detective Howard we have
had that image enlarged and enhanced as
best we can to focus in on that plastic
bag so in a second there'll be an image
that I'm going to show on the screen of
that
a lot of people getting banned again
it's really toxic these days really
toxic
we'll just keep Banning it's free it's a
free button I'm not paying anything
every time I use it
mostly YouTube yeah
people on Twitter behaving I mean it's
you know make of it what you want I
believe this is exhibit number 24.
[Applause]
we're getting close to a break a short
break and then I'll explain everything
where we're at
a lot of consultation Happening Here
I apologize uh we need to do a little
something technical people
let's take a break folks please don't
talk about the case during the break
read watching us during the account of
the Trap
so there will be a break and we'll have
a chance to catch up on everything here
it does seem that we're getting to some
key elements here visual elements of the
test of the um prosecution's exhibits
okay so they're going to be going to a
break now and uh so we'll explain what's
going on so uh Monday we had jury
selection
and a jury was selected I believe it
actually may be 20 total jurors 12 on
the jury and eight alternates correct me
if I'm wrong I believe that's what's at
play here
um yesterday Tuesday was the first
proper day of the trial and we had
opening statements from the prosecution
as well as the defense there was a big
controversy yesterday as to whether the
defense could play a video which
contained elements already
which the prosecution said no we had
these have not yet been entered into
evidence you can't just play a video you
can't present the evidence in the
opening statement you can allude to what
the evidence will show judge basically
said it's fine with a couple minor minor
tweaks
today we are in the first day of uh of
testimony and questioning and uh right
now what we've been seeing is uh
questioning by the prosecutors
of a detective who was on duty the night
of the killings we can call them
killings at this point in time
um
that's where we are there's going to be
a very very short break and I want an
opportunity to go over different things
that people are saying
um
okay let's get to I I do want to thank
people people have been so great
supporting the non-stop streams that
we've been doing this week I want to say
thank you to JP RX gone
mellow Melly herselfat robot Chris
quarkmis and Monstercat for the twitch
Prime subscriptions I am committed to
getting back into the thousand plus
twitch subscriber
area this month and I have only myself
to blame for the fact that we didn't get
there the last couple of months and I
really appreciate that I also want to
say thank you to Greg Mott who just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code felony21 as well as Andy Hickman
who just signed up new members number
seven and eight as you can see here
joinpakman.com it's crazy what's
happening on the website and you can use
the coupon felony21 to get a big
discount I would love it if you did that
really appreciative of everybody who's
been sending me nice messages saying
David we love all the streaming that
you've been doing it's it's all good
um over on court TV they're in a break
it's a break everywhere right now guys
so we can relax and um uh take a moment
just to get caught up
on a few different things here that are
taking place if you missed last night's
election results stream now I have two
let me make sure that I'm telling you
this correctly I believe it's two
minutes from now when at the stroke of 4
P.M on in the East and 1 p.m in the west
I am publishing a video
breaking down last night's election
disaster
for Democrats and it is a disaster the
debate can be over to what degree was
last night a disaster for Democrats but
it was a disaster and it could portend
some very negative things
um for 2022. now New Jersey
gubernatorial results I do want to see
where we are with that
um
let's see here
ask HQ New Jersey
let's see where we are there
uh I guess this is the website site
can't be reached
decision desk
and we want to see New Jersey
it has still not been called but the
incumbent Phil Murphy is now just
slightly back in the lead by about six
tenths of a point about 15 000 votes
okay so we're we're we'll keep an eye on
that of course if you missed last
night's stream
we did have a very weaponized call from
Furious trumpist Jimmy from Philly we've
now uploaded this as a standalone video
um if you missed it let's I'll just play
it for you uh let's check in with Jimmy
from Philly uh Jimmy from Philly James
you're on the air what's going on
uh well a little tidbit about Governor
Murphy in New Jersey
okay mainstream media told everybody
that there was all these curfews for
months people people were all upset and
then a couple months later good old
Governor Murphy with a rice smile said
there was no curfew I never ordered any
curfew
you're gonna vote for a guy like that
that deceives you by omission
and that God just said the suburbs of
Philly yeah that that's all my friends
that move up to Washington Township
because they hate Philadelphia they vote
for that clown
okay all right interesting
yeah
I'll move over the
white Philadelphia they did for
themselves
did they in what way
more money they they got they they did
well in life and they can't stand
Philadelphia
so they move they moved to a suburb and
they made more money than in the city
no they did better in life better in
life but they made more money you said
right
David they don't like Democratic
politicians no that but hold on I'm
actually interested it's ridiculous what
would be an example job where one of
your friends made more money
in the suburbs of Philadelphia in Jersey
than in Philly what's it what job pays
more well first of all the suburbs of
Philadelphia is not New Jersey Oh I
thought you were saying the Philly
suburbs in Jersey that the college won
your callers said that you said that it
sounds illegal that was a joke you know
that was a joke right yeah I know okay
I understand that but a reasonable
person but he's he's being truthful
because a lot of people moved out of
Philadelphia to just across the bridge
got it but so to go back I'm really
interested in job markets what is the
job your friends had who they left okay
to the suburbs my one friend's a trucker
his wife works for uh
what does his wife do his wife makes
more money than him actually she works
for the government somewhere I'm unsure
okay but so they got like five kids so
you know to live in Washington Township
with five kids you gotta have money you
gotta have money to live anywhere David
I lived in Jersey 20 years ago I used to
live to this listen to this talk show
yeah and you they deduced that a single
person 20 years ago
live in a to live in an apartment
maintain a car had to make forty four
thousand dollars a year in New Jersey
I I can only imagine what it is now
Jimmy is it okay if we try to just stick
to one topic and then we'll go to the
next one sure okay so my question is
let's say you were in landscaping I
would guess as a landscaper you make
more working in Philly than in suburbs
because usually Landscaping work is more
expensive in cities so hold on let me
finish the question Jimmy Jimmy I'm
begging you let me finish the question
I'm this I'm sorry
what is the type of job
where you made your friends made more by
quitting the Philly job and getting the
same job in a suburb what is that
I
the truth is David they couldn't stand
living in Philly so it wasn't true when
you said they made more money when they
left they just didn't like Philly
well yes that's part of it you lied you
told me something that wasn't true
I don't know Jimmy you called me but so
so you're saying it's not truthful you
didn't really you don't really have an
example of that
listen David I'm on my third 12 beer so
I don't know what the hell I said to you
to be honest with you okay
uh okay
give me anything else I can do for you
anything well you know Governor Murphy
is a scumbag he allowed the mainstream
media to tell everybody in New Jersey
that there were curfews he never refuted
it then a couple months later with a wry
smile he said what curfews I never
ordered a curfew
yeah I just don't know anything about
that I don't know I don't know a thing
about that that's exactly what he did
David I'm telling you the truth is this
more true than your friend who left
Philly and made more in the summer David
you got to be kidding you're talking
about the truth I mean I'm talking to
you like it
David what was that stream that you said
that you're an admitted liar and like I
have it there's a playlist on my channel
yeah anybody can access I don't know
what you're talking about maybe you were
joking but you said it Jimmy what'd you
have for dinner tonight
but I have no I had a um
I have a bag of gourmet uh microwave
stuff
PF Chang's
PF Changs I've never been there
it's a restaurant but they put out
Gourmet I know what it is I've just
never been there yeah
it's Gourmet are you asking me what I
have for dinner some about the concept
of a bag of food is funny are you
familiar with Pho it's a
um Vietnamese soup or is it Cambodian it
is Vietnamese
sounds gay
all right Jimmy we're gonna let you go
okay thank you there's Jimmy from Philly
when it goes overtly homophobic we just
kill it okay there we go so that was
that was the call yesterday with Jimmy
from Philly so you got clear you missed
a lot of hijinks on the stream last
night okay we're standing by for the
resumption of the trial it's gonna
happen in just a few minutes I want to
say thank you to Sierra loves eggnog
huvian
highgal
pseudonymous and bisnik for signing up
via twitch Prime putting us at 13 and if
you're just joining us we do have a
coupon code it's so cheap
it could be a felony in more
conservative parts of the country the
code is felony 21 and you can sign up on
my website joinpakman.com we joke around
a lot about memberships
but in all in all seriousness
it really is
um when the memberships come in big
massive dumps when the memberships dump
in it really does a lot to support the
work that we do so consider yourselves
invited let's look at a few different
super chats Chris says I think we need a
different judge yeah a little late for
that
um have Jimmy from Philly and Ike from
South Carolina debate it would be lively
that's actually a pretty good idea
great Channel and thank you for your
work nobody sees I hope you don't mean
nobody watches what I do I I think what
you mean is just the behind the scenes
stuff
um people saying it's pronounced fa not
foe I pronounced it fa
guys please criticize me for things I've
said not things I haven't said
there was a really wacky thing I didn't
get a chance to talk about this Michael
Williams from the Dallas news had a
great Thread about this
this was yesterday
here at Dealey Plaza where hundreds of Q
Anon supporters have gathered expecting
John F Kennedy Jr to reveal himself
where his father was assassinated John F
Kennedy Jr died in a plane crash in 99.
the crowd including a group holding a
trump Kennedy sign breaks out into a
rendition of the national anthem a
segment of Q Anon believes JFK Jr who's
been dead for 20 years would run in
2020. let's listen
[Applause]
for the land
okay
um experts who have followed Q Anon for
years said even they were surprised by
the turnout in Dallas frankly I'm kind
of shocked at how many people turned out
for this said Jared Holt
um
a pretty steady rainfall has driven a
big part of the group to cover but the
Lost
I guess it I guess he meant the last
hardcore Q Anon adherence or adherence
are still standing on the grassy knoll
every few seconds passing cars honk
their horns over the x's on the streets
marking where JFK was shot
[Music]
okay taking shelter with a group of
folks who seem to believe Trump will
walk into the White House as president
tomorrow morning now this was last night
uh news from the future it didn't happen
but take a listen to this
come on
a woman holding a dog is about to tell
us
about 1 30 A.M
why imagine thinking
all day yesterday
that at 1 30 in the morning Trump was
going to fly into the White House and
become president again
like that's not even oh you know I like
banana split you don't like it or white
chocolate's good no no I disagree oh
okay all right
Trump will fly to the White House and
regain the presidency that 72-hour psych
hold folks that's 72 hours cycled level
um I don't know what else to say it just
that's what it is
um I do want to say a huge thank you to
Jill karlier who just signed up on my
website using the coupon code felony21
Jill you our new member number 14 today
number 14. we are also getting
dangerously close to the 900 twitch
subscriber level which is going to put
us in really great position to get to
903 which will put us close to 905 which
will get us to 909.
Etc to a thousand that's really kind of
the point uh let's go to some voicemails
I had no opportunity yesterday to go
through voicemails during the evening
stream
um I do want to uh play at least some
for you here's one from Eric from
Massachusetts
[Music]
hello in your narrative out of it it's
funny with the with the Boston accent
whistleblowers he said from fisa I hear
f-i-s-a but I believe he means Pfizer
um like I said vaccine's dangerous
killing people and all he can say is
about your career and uh on uh YouTube
and whatever uh with your business why
is the better write you a big check
because it's all over
okay so as far as Eric's concerned the
fact that I report the science of
vaccines is going to make me it's not
clear if I'm going to end up in jail or
just with no show oh we did hear from
Whit early this morning
David so
a lot of people are talking about how
people aren't getting vaccinated and
then they're losing their job like they
should not be required to be vaccinated
that's true the topic of vaccines has
been a big topic you've actually
accurately represented that in case like
maybe they thought that like
or
in case they on the off chance they
wanted to get pregnant okay
um more voicemails just continue to pour
in
sir I wanted to call you and let you
know that mangoes where I live are 99
cents as a regular price whoa I live in
Virginia about an hour and a half
outside of DC sir I believe that the
farther north you go the more expensive
the mangoes will be because of the cost
of Transportation I will tell you we
just had mangoes on sale sir for 79
cents for one mango can you imagine I
would be stocking up if they weren't
perishable you know so I got plenty of
mangoes I have five mangoes sitting here
right now and if I was close big spender
huh imagine just sitting around covered
in mangoes too sir I'm
sorry I mango thank you for your service
all right so getting the mango material
out of the way
uh
see what else we've got here
hey David Friday's show had some
depressing colors so I thought I was
right in the mood I found a show right
before the pandemic and it completed my
turn to politics so I've been a
congressional intern sir my
representative Paul Hummer and I
absolutely loved it wow okay I I got
somebody involved in politics that's
very exciting
hello David I just listened to an
episode on a podcast I'm a super busy
single mom but you had a caller who had
called in about Adult Day Care and a lot
of the things that she explained and
talked about were issues that we suffer
with in rural Alaska I'm from Alaska and
we have talked about multi-generational
care and the possibilities I think that
there is a lot of people who are on that
and I just wanted to say please if
you're doing that pursue it excellent
idea very good I think we've got a
Spanish voicemail here
hi good morning David for some reason
the the transcript is in Spanish even
though the voicemail is in English
that's weird
and I'll leave my phone number eight
three one two hold on a second oh my God
hold on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh my
God hold on whoa mute everything oh my
God
uh
all right let's I just I'm just not even
gonna play it okay thank you
hey David I was just wondering they say
that most black people with the most
um people of color don't get vaccinated
and I think that is because we have a
disproportion in the models
um
what
all right well that failed
hi David this is Lee from Minnesota love
the show I'm just wondering uh what
happened to the Patriot male certainly
it hasn't that they couldn't have come
to an end
um yeah we had we addressed that already
upon advice from the FBI we ended hatred
mail actually and I've addressed it
before I'm not going to keep calling
attention to it though
David this is Whitney
um
so I have like a couple questions just
from like uh like
uh Jewish
um German relations
and
um like I feel like uh
we were
really kind of like uneven ground when
it came to like the Holocaust and
helping like the Holocaust Survivors
like it was like you know not
um okay it's history with Whitney
hi David I'm calling you sorry
um I'm calling you because I have some
thoughts about
um
the climate change Summit uh
specifically having to meet in person I
mean I really hope at some point this
idea that you have to get together with
somebody you have to look them in the
eye you know you have to be face to face
with somebody just goes away it it
happened actually it's sort of coming
back now and we realize that some things
actually a lot of things could have been
an email didn't even need to be a zoom
meeting
but then there are things where you do
actually get more done in person I don't
I don't think that's illegitimate by any
means by any means whatsoever
but your answer to a caller who was
wondering about Trump did different than
any other Republican prior to him and uh
you were partially correct
had Donald Trump though not had started
out his campaign
hijacking economic populist talking
points from Bernie Sanders he would not
have gotten the attention of the average
Joe redneck who is not well read who
barely pays attention to the news other
than maybe Fox for a half hour he comes
home from work that's not that's not a
crazy take actually that's kind of
interesting a few other super chats
coming in Jeremy says hey David sir love
your education and your show I don't
even know what I'm doing sir I'm from
Montreal and really wish there was a
Canadian French equivalent of your show
oh well until then I'm supporting your
channel sir
sir
right
what's scarier than these conspiracy
theories like JFK Jr coming back from
the dead is that the folks that believe
them vote Yes
sir the Virginia gubernatorial race
almost always goes to the candid
opposite the president sir I think
you're doing very well for young and not
to win would have been highly unusual I
addressed that on my segment today
okay where do people like Marjorie
Taylor green come from by the take
they're in the position they're in it's
too late see upcoming Michelle Fiore yes
I covered Michelle Fiore
David big fan of the show finally ponied
up keep at it thank you
doctor says things are looking Bleak
enough I kind of wish I could flee the
country I don't want to raise my family
here yeah a lot of people are feeling
that
um Ren says sir I don't even know what
I'm doing sir do you believe if Kyle
Rittenhouse was African Or Hispanic
descent he would be in jail or even
currently alive I think that without a
doubt everything would have been
different if Kyle Rittenhouse were
African-American
No Doubt
Dave I'm from Canada very confused why
are the dead protesters not allowed to
be called victims in the trial they were
shot dead in the street yeah the judge
said that what the trial is about
whether they were victims or whether it
was self-defense if it was self-defense
they're not victims so the judge said
you can't refer to them as victims this
judge has done it before it is not
typical of all murder trials it is not
typical of all murder trials that's for
sure we learned that very very strongly
I want to say a huge thank you to master
mcleavy as well as Finn Panda who just
grabbed twitch Prime subscriptions
pumping us up to 16 today
um love everybody's support via all
means we love twitch Prime
um we love website you can sign up on my
website as well let's listen to a few
more voicemails
hi David this is Bob from Ohio I just
watched your
um video on the Cleveland Guardians
um just a couple things to add to that
um they have changed their name in the
past they were the maps they were named
after one of their players in Napoleon
allows your way and they changed it when
he moved to another team and I think
it's a good idea to do this uh the
Washington football team did I wish they
would have come up with a name but right
okay so there have been name changes in
the past I think that that's absolutely
true
hey David I was listening to tonight's
show and heard a lot of pain in people's
voices so I thought I'd pass along a
super easy tip for people who are really
anxious and stressed oh okay and in pain
it's called The Meta meditation oh okay
um
spelled m-e-t-t-a and you use a phrase
over and over for 15 minutes a day the
one I use is let me add some music to it
may all beings be happy
may all beings be healthy may all beings
be free from suffering
there's something about sending out that
heartfelt pulse into the world that
changes your brain chemistry yep I know
because I tried it yeah no but no
meditation is excellent meditation is
excellent
um all right let's we we are about to
get back to this here
um thanks to E Lawrence for signing up
via twitch Prime love it absolutely love
it we are getting back into the trial
um
oh would you come down please yes thank
you
okay
uh what do you guys think about a
mustache related coupon code maybe
something we could look at
mustache 21.
could be a pretty big discount
maybe for tomorrow
a lot of fun being had over at the
defense table that's for sure
so we're resuming with the prosecution's
questioning of the detective who was on
duty the night of the shooting and
um they had a technical element to sort
out and I will I think they've done it
and so the volume is up guys there's
just no audio coming from the court and
uh
we're expecting it all to resume uh
momentarily here
Daniel says why all the talk about
goobers M Ms are better
okay
sometimes I don't even know what my
audience is talking about
let's see what's happening over on court
TV they appear to be in some kind of a
commercial
we'll keep it over here the audio is
going in and out we are I'm keeping the
audio on all the time it's just that the
audio is going in and out
um
maybe we can even squeeze in one or two
more voicemails while we wait here
David uh my name is guy I'm a medical
student and uh I I can't I just can't
deal with that noise guy that's that's
just that's just crazy
hey David I love your see now this is
clear audio this is how you deliver a
voicemail you
[Music]
do for an anti
-master that are claiming it's their
body their choice that they'll remember
that next time they attend an
anti-abortion Rally or good that ship
has sailed hypocrisy doesn't matter
anymore it just doesn't
um I want to say thanks to Andy B 7301
who's new member number 18 today
let's kick up I would love to actually
get to get to um get to a hundred let me
do an extra thing right now website
memberships count double every website
membership we're gonna count as two and
every patreon pledge we're counting is
three today I'm just that interested in
getting us to a hundred so twitch sub
counts as one website membership counts
as two
patreon counts as three I'm monitoring
all of these different elements let's
see if we can make it happen
hello David this is Harry from
California I'm calling with regards to
the ongoing uh social social security
scammers you've done
okay and uh that one was interrupted
Midway
let's see
um I do have I have Troy York I also
have a b dog voicemail
hey pack dog
it's your boy b-dog just giving you a
call dog I want to get your take on this
um if you were in charge of the
democratic party today dog what would
you do going forward to recover from the
disastrous election night last night dog
I'll take my answer off the air pack dog
big fan by the way though yeah I I have
a whole segment about that today so I it
just published actually to YouTube
um let's see if we can squeeze in
a Troy York voicemail
from earlier today
where was the Troy York stuff
he's been leaving some doozies I haven't
even yet been getting to them
so David you're a spreader of Lies just
like this is not Troy York by the way
it's the cnns and things like that that
too you know the truth is your
kryptonites and you know it's one thing
to to be a part of a situation or you
believe in something but you know you
never your party is all about no
accountability and trust me Southern
Public what's he talking about things
are too but majority uh you guys could
ever admit hey we're wrong or I'm sorry
like we we're supposed to teach our kids
okay I don't know what he's talking
about
is that still in a position where
everybody's able to see it on both ends
okay Court TV wanted to take them Howard
before we took a break I was uh showing
you a still from exhibit number two
which is the Drew Hernandez video number
zero two nine which was a uh focused on
Mr Rosenbaum do you recall that yes
thanks Kevin for signing up screen
exhibit number 24 which is a sort of a
blown up and enhanced photo of that
scene of Mr rosenbaugh
and again uh Detective Howard does that
show the plastic bag that Mr Rosenbaum
was carrying around on the evening of
August 25th 2020. that's what it appears
to be yes all right now I would like to
show exhibit number nine which is the
aerial surveillance video from the FBI
thanks thanks to Shannon and Kareem for
signing up on my website they count
double so two counts is four wow
thanks to Patron Jody counts as three
making some real progress here
does anyone think that even just this
first day of testimony is being properly
kept track of and evaluated by the
jurors do you think they have that
capacity on average
yikes basically everybody's saying no
we can pause that please
can you now please play exhibit number
26.
foreign
and now if we can please play exhibit
number 25.
I believe it is a fair criticism to
wonder whether the prosecution so far is
even approaching this in a way that will
come off being a coherent story to the
jurors I think it's too early to say how
they will tie all of this together it is
too early to say
right what is being shown that's a good
question
so the arrows pointing to people of
Interest that's the point of this and I
agree maybe it would be more effective
if the prosecution was narrating in some
way beginning of that and then pause
please I'm going to replay it yes of
that same video
Detective Howard the video that we just
watched here at the beginning of the
video here we go pause there for a
second there are two individuals
identified one has a circle around them
with uh the label Person of Interest one
the second has a square around them with
a label of perseverance Person of
Interest two do you see that yes based
on your investigation your review of all
the other videos who are those two
individuals
Person of Interest one is Joseph
Rosenbaum and
Person of Interest two is Kyle
Rittenhouse
now can you please play the video again
Brian
now we have context
presumably
the point the prosecution wants to make
here
uh
is that Kyle Rittenhouse was an
aggressor of sorts although understand
now at this point Kyle Rittenhouse is in
front of the eventual victim he seems to
turn around and maybe that's when he
fires the gun is that possible that
that's what we're seeing
okay thank you
your honor I have a number of uh
exhibits that I've just used I believe
they are exhibits one the Drew Hernandez
video zero two three
exhibit number two the Drew Hernandez
video zero to nine exhibit number four
this Minsky after Rosenbaum shooting
video exhibit number five the BG on the
scene video exhibit number six the CJ TV
running video exhibit number eight the
Elijah Riot video exhibit number nine
was just played it has already been
admitted to evidence that is the FBI
video
exhibit number 12 which is the Kyle Cook
video
exhibit number 13 which is the Lakota
lichtwalt live stream
exhibit number 14 which is the reg
Incognito live stream
exhibit 15 Richie McGinnis at
rosenbaum's body exhibit 16 Richie
McGinnis Kyle interview number 17 Richie
McGinnis walking with Kyle number 18
rundown live video and number 19 the
Drew Hernandez shooting video I would
move on also there is exhibit 24 which
is a photo of Joseph Rosenbaum and the
plastic bag
exhibit 25 and FBI video with markings
annotated at normal speed and then
exhibit number 26 which is a second FBI
video with markings which shows the
um five it's a five second clip from
second 23 to 2nd to 28. I would move all
of those exhibits into evidence
the testimony that you've provided today
Detective Howard and the videos that
we've seen of all of these events that
you've identified as occurring in the
area of Sheridan Road between
approximately 59th Street and 63rd
Street
did everything that we've heard about
and seen in this case occur here in the
city and county of Kenosha in the state
of Wisconsin yes we've also heard
testimony regarding a person who we've
identified as the defendant Kyle
Rittenhouse do you see him here in court
yes can you point him out for us please
he's the gentleman
sitting
at the corner of that table between uh
Mr sharafsi
Miss wisco
I have nothing for that
oh
now the defense will get to question
this Detective
okay
I will eventually thank you
I'm sure you were detective with the
Kenosha Police Department yes do you
work for the Kenosha Police Department
yes how long have you been a detective
almost three years
before that you're a patrol officer yes
you don't work for the District
Attorney's Office correct correct your
job is to gather facts so that in some
cases they can be presented to citizens
of Kenosha to make a determination on
the guilt or in a sense of criminal
defendants correct yes and that is
supposed to be done
um without prejudice or fear or favor
correct yes and it's as Joel Friday used
to say in the old days just the facts
correct yes now in this case you are one
of the lead detectives yes
and you put innumerable amounts of time
into this case correct yeah months
months and before August 23rd
there were three car sources in Kenosha
Wisconsin correct yes the first one was
burnt to the ground on
the Knights of the 24th correct yes
the second car Source where Kyle
Rittenhouse and other individuals were
protecting and there was video shown
that was an ongoing business protected
on the 24th correct yes and it wasn't
boarded up like it's shown in the videos
correct correct that was boarded up
because of the civil unrest that was
occurring in Kenosha correct and going
on to car Source 3 where the first
shooting happened that was an ongoing
business not boarded up not damaged
correct correct now in gathering
evidence in cases like this
routinely
you go out and you freeze a crime scene
and you get as much evidence you take
time you photograph things and you get
it all so that it's all preserved is the
right word correct correct in this case
because of the chaos
on the night of the 25th into the
morning of the 26th that wasn't able to
be done Fair statement
not to the degree that we typically do
and I'm not trying to put blame or but I
want this jury to be able to understand
the situation this is part of the cops
messed up narrative routine for a small
contained homicide scene
to not be able to find shell casings and
have to go back three days later when
they're pointed out by citizens that's
not routine it was four days later oh
yeah I apologize so even longer yeah and
a citizen said hey there's shell casings
under this car you guys should come out
and get them I don't know that the
prosecutor should be nodding to the line
of inquiry from the defense
thorough investigation where you guys
put the cones down you photograph
everything and then you could bring all
that forward correct
evidence text gathered what they were
able to observe that night
that evidence technicians were gathering
what they were able to observe that
night okay
and what I'm getting at is there was
nothing hiding those shell cases if they
had done a thorough inspection looked
under the cars and things like that
correct correct it is a car line correct
now you went and got a bunch of
information in this case through
documents is that a first statement yes
you did multiple search warrants yes you
did multiple subpoenas for records
correct correct and a lot of those
search warrants were directed at my
clients social media correct correct his
telephone
correct
um
I'm sure I'm gonna miss somebody
Instagram Tick Tock all of those yes if
it were me and I wanted to slow down the
momentum of the defense attorney
I would actually make him ask me a
question rather than let him keep going
and just going yes yes yeah those aren't
really questions and one technique that
prosecutors I've spoken to have
mentioned is you actually stop and you
say I what is the when he goes social
media
and the shell casings and Twitter and
yes you actually make them ask you the
question every time companies it's there
they provide it to you you get it
correct yeah the first thing we'll
typically do is send a preservation
letter to preserve the record then on
search warrant subpoena those can come a
little bit further down the road and
you get all that information so that
you're able to provide the jury a full
and complete picture of a suspect or a
defendant yes the best that we can and
you've looked through all those
documents yes now
in this case there's a lot of
how should I say it
um interest in subjects cell phones
correct yes and cell phones
are for lack of a better word many
computers that have videos personal
thoughts
um
just about anything that a person did
Fair statement yes and in this and just
so people understand I won't keep
interrupting if this detective wanted to
be difficult even to that he could say
I investigate crimes I can't comment as
to the social importance of what a
smartphone has now become
I'm a detective my investigate crimes
you you make it difficult for the
attorney to establish this entire story
correct
Tory technique that law enforcement uses
correct correct consent search warrant
one or the other yes and you hold the
phone
so that if they don't consent nothing
can be destroyed deleted yes if they
consent you have somebody in your
department who's
main duty is downloading cell phones yes
there are some cell phones that are not
if I use the wrong word crackable
correct okay and that means that
unless you're folks asking about closed
captions let's see if on the court TV
website uses correct correct consent
search warrant one or the other it
doesn't seem too bad and you hold the
phone
so that if they don't consent there we
go nothing can be destroyed deleted yes
if they consent you have somebody in
your department who's
main duty is downloading cell phones yes
there are some cell phones that are not
I use the wrong word crackable all right
okay and that means that unless you have
the exact finger code or a fingerprint
or something it can't be opened correct
Mr rittenhouse's phone was on the the
latest IOS and there was not software
available at that time iOS stands for
it's an Apple update okay but it's it's
an operating system it's a type yes okay
and back in 2020 when uc's Mr
rittenhouse's phone
you wanted to get in the phone you
immediately sent it to the FBI so that
it could be opened or cracked and they
told you they couldn't do that correct
correct and
myself and Mr Rittenhouse found out
about that correct correct and we said
you want to get in this phone we'll give
you the code as long as we get a copy of
whatever you take correct correct and
those arrangements were made and his
phone was downloading correct so there's
nothing hidden
correct now in this case you got a
search warrant on September 24th
I apologize in this case on September
23rd of 2020 you got assigned search
warrant from Judge Wagner for Gage girls
with this phone correct correct and that
was in preparation for a meeting that
was going to occur on September 24th
between yourself Gage groskwitz his
lawyer and members from the District
Attorney's Office correct I believe that
to be correct but I was not able to
attend that meeting okay who attended it
Detective antaranian and I'm not sure
who else but
the meeting was in person yes okay so
search Warren in one hand correct yes
telephone Mr gross quits presumably and
Mr grosskit's Hand yes and for some
reason that search warrant was never
served at Mr gross Swiss and his phone
taken correct correct so you have
a video from Mr girl switch's phone
correct
correct but you don't have the download
of his telephone correct
and you wanted to download his phone
correct yes you wanted the information
that was in that phone yes you had a
search warrant to get all the
information in that phone yes and yet
you didn't execute it no I did not okay
do you know why it wasn't executed
concerns with Marcy's law who had the
concerns with Marcy's law
several of us did I did attorneys did
when you say attorneys you're talking
about attorney Binger correct correct
Marcy's law is the victim rights
amendment correct correct and have you
ever not executed a search warrant
because of Marcy's law no okay this is
the first time ever
is it the last time ever
I can't foresee the future
since that date September 24th of 2020
to today have you ever not executed a
signed search warrant by a Judicial
officer of Kenosha County because of
some concern of Marcy's law no yeah and
there was also objections from
his attorney who didn't want to give it
over to you correct correct
when you interviewed Dominic black
you're shaking your head no no detective
answering me an interview Dominic black
I interviewed Wendy Faith the Mackenzie
writtenhouse at that time you
interviewed Dominic black on I believe
it was November 6th of the follow-up
interview yes okay that was when he was
under arrest correct yes
and
that interview
was taped correct yes the interview with
Bretton and I'm going to butcher his
name the individual who's responsible
for BG on the scene that's Brennan guten
schwager okay you said it thank you
um when he interviewed him that was
taped I believe so the interview and I'm
not saying you interviewed him but the
interview of Richie McGinnis in the
Kenosha Police Department that was Kate
I believe so
when
the interview was performed
with Mr groskwitz and his attorney Ms
Motley
that interview wasn't taped I don't
believe so okay
can you think of any other Witnesses in
this case complaining Witnesses whose
interviews and information was not taped
other complaining Witnesses yeah
no okay
and just sort of the record's clear
no one has ever interviewed jump kickman
correct correct no one's ever been able
to identify not that I'm aware of he's
never come forward and complained to law
enforcement that he felt as though he
was somehow the victim of a crime on
August 25th correct
and he never came he
you tried to identify him we tried you
tried showing his picture around asking
numerous people
yes
now you testified about Mr zaminski
correct correct now
after getting a bunch of the videos
which you did get you review those and
you realize correct me if I'm wrong that
Kyle Rittenhouse did not fire the first
shot correct and through some Facebook
sleuthing it's brought out that an
individual by the name of Alec or Blaine
was the individual who in fact had done
or fired the first shot on the 25th yeah
I believe it was Al explained what's
going around social media and different
Outlets but yeah I saw the name
okay and through getting his picture off
Facebook
that picture was
circulated around your department yes
and he was a known individual and
somebody says that's not Alec Blaine
that's Joshua's correct and
do you know who that was
information was forwarded to our gangs
gang crimes unit at the time and uh I
believe they had a resource in Milwaukee
that they helped coordinate identity
guys do we even want the closed captions
they're completely toxic I mean it's
just nonsense it's the equivalent of
that sign language interpreter who is
signing nonsense one shot you said Mr
bully I apologize Mr zaminski
the real name who fired a shot shortly
before Mr Rosenbaum
was shot by Kyle yes now
on direct examination you were asked a
question about the timing from zaminski
shot
to Kyle's shot correct correct you did
that with a stopwatch yes so it's it's a
human act yes okay and
the Wisconsin State Crime Lab has
numerous individuals who can break down
video correct yes you can do a frame by
frame analysis of the video and that can
tell you frames per second and you can
come within hundredths of a second of
what happened correct correct and
whether Mr zaminski was on the sidewalk
or Mr zaminski was on the beginning of
the parking lot
where you see the flash on the video is
behind Kyle Rittenhouse correct at that
time yes okay and the shot goes off and
it's in close proximity
30 feet Yes okay and
from behind him yes
and you were asked questions by Mr
Binger about Mr Rosenbaum and your
information regarding him and he named a
series of weapons
um gun knife
I think there was even a bat or
something like that
in your extensive review of the videos
there were numerous times where Mr
Rosenbaum was on correct I can recall
him carrying a chain okay at one point
and to the best of your ability and
investigation that chain came from a
trailer
from the Saint James campus and the St
James you're talking about the rubble
and things like that yes and that was an
area where there's more videos of people
going and arming themselves
with projectiles wax or busted up cement
yes and that was where Mr Rosenbaum and
Mr zaminski got
the trailer to bring down Sheridan Road
to start the fire correct correct and
that's where Mr zaminski and Mr
Rosenbaum are bent over starting the
clump of debris and things like that
in the road on fire with the trailer up
on its side yes and that's where Mr
Rosenbaum is wearing a blue mask correct
correct and that's what we commonly be
refer to as a bachelor or a shield that
goes from guys
he's talking about a balaclava baklava
is a delicious dessert
maroon shirt that he was wearing on his
head
as a mask when he was shot by my client
correct now
as you said you've been a detective for
three years it's against the law to use
physical Force against the citizen of
Kenosha to try and steal their property
from them correct correct that would be
what's called strong armed robbery
correct it's a more serious crime if you
attempt to do that while you are masked
that's what's called a criminal enhancer
correct correct
baklava
it's gonna back up a little bit to your
direct examination
you talked
in response to Mr binger's questions
about the pumps being turned off at gas
stations correct correct now that isn't
something that was publicized or
everybody knew correct correct so the
crowd and people who are protecting the
ultimate gas station didn't necessarily
know that the pumps were off
they may not have you didn't you didn't
broadcast it correct
and you testified about that's another
example when you can just interrupt the
thing rather than saying it's possible
say I have no knowledge at all about who
knew anything about gas pumps
uh Patrol police presence in the
downtown area on the 25th really was it
there was some Patrol were anybody
walking the beat
not walking okay and they were in
unmarked squad cars we had unmarked and
Mark Squad first
in the videos during the evening from
say nine o'clock until midnight when
this happens you don't see any police
cars on the street correct
well we we tried to surveil from a
distance away okay and gather as much
information without
making yourself public or no yes
and the night before
on the 24th
there was limited or no response by
emergency Personnel that's why carsource
one burned to the ground correct
we had to prioritize to go to certain
calls I I unders sir I'm not trying to
second-guess anybody I'm trying to set
the scene that evening
went to car Source what I refer to as
one the lot that was wiped out with fire
trucks to put it out correct correct or
you're not responding to just property
damage at that time oh man
thanks Marcus for signing up on my
website by the way I appreciate it you
interviewed
BG on the scene Brett and grad schweiger
and he was interviewed at the Kenosha
Police Department correct and in your
interview A Hymn immediately you read
him his Miranda rights correct
correct and that was because when he was
arrested
there was talk of one a curfew ticket
correct correct and two he was found
with marijuana
actually do not recall the marijuana
aspect of that you're not disputing that
are you I'm not going to dispute it okay
and
there he gives a statement there was
discussion in that one about downloading
his phones and Camera correct and
that was done
I believe for that he was able to
airdrop the his video to my work cell
phone okay so he provided you with
everything you wanted from his phone and
you did not have to get a search warrant
correct and you leave the interview
and you said on the tape you call
somebody and you tell
Mr Gooden schweiger when you come back
in that you
don't have to cite him or arrest him for
the marijuana because you spoke to
somebody at the DA's office he didn't
remember them do you remember that
not verbatim no do you remember telling
him he got to go home and he wasn't
going to be held overnight yes okay you
don't arrest somebody for a curfew
violation you give them a ticket correct
correct that's a forfeiture right so
there had to be some criminal activity
or when he was done being interviewed he
could have just went home you can't
threaten
somebody with a rest when you're
interviewing I think you kind of can
actually
does this guy know what anything about
police interrogations they threaten
things all the time
he had marijuana in his person correct
correct you have
no ability to make promises or give
consideration for cooperation correct
we wanted the video more than to cite
him for curfew or marijuana okay
okay did you get permission from to not
charge him with the marijuana I don't
recall getting permission it's been a
decision that detective and answering me
that I made okay
I don't recall getting permission for
that that may have been a decision that
detective answer Amy and I made
and
you
that evening are made lead detective
along with Detective answer aiming on
this case yes and you receive
information
that your person who has not been
identified yet has turned himself into
the Antioch Police Department correct
and you and detective anaranium excuse
me
go down to Antioch Illinois correct you
talk to the people who are there about
when he got there correct correct and
that was at approximately 1 20 a.m
correct correct so that would have been
one hour and 30 minutes from the time of
the shooting correct
and you get down there at what time at
approximately 3 30. okay so he'd been
there for a little over two hours two
hours and 10 minutes when you get there
correct correct and was he in handcuffs
no was he locked up in a holding cell no
he was sitting in the unlocked Lobby
the Antioch Police Department with his
mother waiting for you yes
the Antioch police didn't have somebody
sitting on him
I don't know you walked in there and
there wasn't a police officer sitting
next to him was there don't recall I do
not recall that
and you documented the injuries on Kyle
yes and I guess what the state is
getting at is
the injuries weren't serious so he
shouldn't have shot Fair
Fair okay
when you're being kicked in the head you
don't know what's going to happen to you
is that a fair statement Fair okay when
somebody's hitting you in the back of
the head
the second time with a skateboard you
don't know what's happening to you
correct correct when somebody puts their
bare hand on your firearm trying to take
it away from your person you don't know
whether or not that person is going to
get your gun and turn it and use it on
you correct you don't know no correct
and
it's a general training principle
you don't give up your gun because it's
a deadly and dangerous weapon right on
the objective this line here this is not
an expert witness and that this last
question is about training for police
officers which is not relevant
rephrase your question
sir
if a woman is taken from somebody it can
be used against them as a deadly and
dangerous weapon correct correct
now
you looked at
exhibit 18.
and
the prosecutor showed you one hour and
25 minutes into it at approximately 10
seconds I'll get it up on the screen
I'll take this as an opportunity to say
thanks to Red leader well well wedge as
well as pathless Mist also huge huge
huge thank you to Marcus Neely who just
signed up on my website
1 25 10.
this one wasn't
um
otherwise I'll lose it I still believe
Rittenhouse will be not guilty of murder
I still think about it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't see the time I'm
quite a bag
a minute
and one hour 24 minutes and 30 seconds
from the back end
progressions
[Music]
organized
yeah
all right I'll see if I can do it this
way
do you remember
in the video when
the dumpsters out in the street and Kyle
goes out and grabs the dumpster yes okay
and when Kyle pulls the dumpster back
person who's filming takes the camera
and shows an individual standing in the
street staring at my client at a
dumpster correct
I would like to see the video again just
to make sure
yeah
thanks to pay the dackman for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
felony21 really appreciate it your new
member number 4041 because website
memberships count twice today today only
this is some consultation Happening Here
also thanks to Blueberry babe and Lena
Ray for the twitch Subs
cribe ready
his patience he should go inside yeah
if you guys can switch them out just
that it's amazing Loose Cannon he he's
got a lot of rage he said
I'm showing you
run down live
exhibit number 18
3.55 into the video standing right here
who is this that is Kelly zaminski
please continue
the wrong thing this whole problem
protect your property they're respecting
that just keep it there
foreign
[Applause]
I was like
oh
you know who this is right here I'm
playing with the pointer I believe
that's Joshua zaminsky
the dumpster right here
if that stands for you you're referring
to yes there was a little literal
dumpster fire at this event right
[Applause]
project your property they're respecting
that just keep it there
that's not a joke I've recall them
mentioning a dumpster that was on fire
there's a dumpster that's part of this
people think I'm kidding
[Applause]
that's Kyle going out to get the
dumpster on the street correct correct
there you go dumpster that dumpster came
from car Source two slot correct I don't
know that
anyone I understand
hey your job isn't to be in the street
you gotta stand your
that's him holding a dumpster out of the
street correct
property that's why you got problems
already with people
who's this that's Joshua zaminsky he's
standing in front of carsource three
looking directly at car Source three
correct correct in the direction of the
dumpster being brought back by my client
I think he's looking more towards the
videographer okay
is
correct correct
he stands there and we know that he's
armed correct correct
and in doing all the videos
that you viewed
putting out fires upset
these individuals who are starting the
players is that a fair statement that's
fair
exhibit eight please
a direct examination you were asked
questions about
non-lethal correct correct and that was
in response to my client
saying the statement about they didn't
have any non-lethal correct
correct and that non-lethal almost not
almost also doesn't mean
oh nice sticks OC spray and things like
that there are what are considered
non-lethal bullets
can you say that again could you ask a
question please bullets that are meant
to kill
dismember name correct correct they're
also bullets that go in firearms that
are what are referred to as non-lethal
yeah rubber bullets yes could be one of
those projectiles yes and as far as you
know none of the people out there that
evening like my client who are
protecting property and themselves
we're armed with non-lethal bullets
correct not that I'm aware of okay
foreign
approximately 3 58 p.m are you 358 into
the video Excuse me while they cue this
up huge thank you to Marie Gian Greco
who just signed up on my website davidco
and Falafel wrap our newest member what
a day
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is pretty scuffed yeah
then try 358 I'm sorry
thanks beast mode for the twitch sub
appreciate it
very strong subscription so sort of
white dude houses talk to or whatever he
is right here he just got he just got
his whole slept
you got his phone slapped out on me it's
getting sucked at the same time this
dude right here walking away this dude
right here got his phone slapped and and
uh blindsided
stop just hear that yell three times
friendly friendly friendly yes
based upon your investigation who is
that that appears to be Mr Rittenhouse
okay
and that's when he's being chased by Mr
rosenbaugh
I don't know I don't know if it's right
before the chase but approximately the
start of the chase time is when that
audio appears to come out okay and that
would be something to say
to someone I don't have a beef with you
friendly friendly
yes
and that didn't persuade Mr Rosenbaum
based upon your investigation and
viewing of the videos from continue to
attempt to attack my client correct
correct and
as my client is running from Mr
Rosenbaum is he gaining ground on Mr
Rosenbaum or is Mr Rosenbaum gaining
ground on him looks like Mr Rosenbaum is
gradually gaining ground on this
writtenhouse and
Mr Rosenbaum
is running towards my client and my
client turns around and points the gun
in his direction does not level it at
him but makes it very clear that he's
armed to Mr Rosenbaum correct correct
and Mr Rosenbaum is not dissuaded by
that firearm and continues to chase
after my client he stops briefly and
then continues to run again he doesn't
stop like
I'm standing here and say contemplating
life's realities like maybe I should
pick a better course of action
he slows his gate and then there's a
snark on this guy correct correct
and
Kyle runs I'm terrible with my
directions in a self question
southwesternly Direction
how is the judge doing correct you guys
hear that you've seen the Lucas and in
video correct correct and
even in this video you hear like a bang
bang repeatedly correct correct and
based upon your investigation what is
that those are bats or other blunt
objects hitting cars in The Car Store
slot and in the Lucas anden video which
is
a little over seven minutes
that's taken from the 63rd looking in a
North easterly Direction into the car
Source yes mainly North okay and there's
well more than 50 people they're bashing
car windows jumping on cars and starting
a fire there
so I'd say there's more than 50 people
there but it's a
might be a little less than that with
people that are actually doing property
damage because there are a lot of people
that are standing around because there
probably weren't enough cars for
everybody to feed on is that a fair
statement
I don't think it's already kind of like
the the
object is overall
there were only so many cars correct
there's a limit there's a certain number
of cars in the car Source correct and
back when carsource was a running
business those weren't junk cars they
were real cars of somebody's property
correct they were cars for sale and and
correct me if I'm wrong did you ever
hear any of these rioters give an
explanation for why
destroying somebody's property
is going to make their situation or Mr
Blake's situation better
my object because
well the uh one of the exceptions the
hearsay rule is a plan
or a statement of intent
um so the objections will rule
I have not heard a reason
now
the video
of car Source that's shown from the FBI
fixed Wayne aircraft that's at nine
thousand feet correct I can't recall the
exact I think it was that 8 500 89 yeah
I mean High okay you and I'll agree on
that and you can see this bag clear as
day flying through it correct flying
through the air the plastic bag yeah
yes okay and there was also we're right
here
that's the video we're talking about and
pointer excuse me
this right here I'm putting in the lower
right hand corner of the television
there's a number 8 941 feet correct test
was in between our I said 8500 you said
9000.
and here is the latitude longitude
yes and
this
cursor for your information is what
controls the camera where they put that
cursor
the camera locks onto that and the plane
keeps moving correct that's what it
appears to that appears to control the
direction of the camera yes we have a
heat
here we have a a heat tweet Source heat
Source we see some white there yes which
would mean hot yes
and here in the car which I'll refer to
as the Duramax at the northeast corner
of carsource we also have a heat Source
yes and there's a video of an individual
right before my client gets there
starting at Duramax on fire yes
do you have
this exhibit is
no this is up
this exhibit
nines the FBI video from a distance
correct yes you looked at this on
numerous occasions yes and probably the
best way to get to find somebody on this
video is to go backwards so we know
where the shooting was correct yes and
so you follow it backwards that's how
you identify Kyle that's how you
identify Mr Rosenbaum correct that and
relating it to other videos yes and in
this video you're able to get Mr and Mrs
sabinski also correct yes could I have
ours
foreign
[Music]
foreign
there is a green for Kelly zaminski
we'll roll this
and white
go ahead please
stop
this blue circle between
what I would say the second and third
row of cars Mr Rosenbaum correct correct
this red is
Mr zaminsky Green
breezes yes white okay yes and Richie
McGinnis is to the left of the
television screen correct to the right
and pink to the right of the television
screen
abroad please
stop
Miss Kyle the white circle comes to the
Duramax
this individual Mr Rosenbaum begins to
come out in his hiding place Jesse comes
around the vehicle at that time and he's
masked yes and he comes around Raw
stop
blue again Mr Rosenbaum correct correct
and now you begin with the chase Mr
Rosenbaum of power in the house correct
correct not yet
correct me if I'm wrong but this looks
like a classic ambush
I'm going to object this to the calling
for the defendant's interpretation of
things the jury can make their own
decision as to what they are sustained
Mr Rosenbaum is in hiding that's right
correct
it appears so yes my client gets to this
side of the Duramax which
The Far Side from Mr Rosenbaum correct
can you repeat that please my client
comes to the far side of the Duramax
from
Mr rose on the opposite side of Mr
Rosenbaum yes his Circle my client is
stationary and his circle is closing at
my client Circle Mr Rittenhouse correct
correct and according to this video
which we don't have sound because it's
from 9000 feet this is right about the
time where Kyle is friendly friendly
friendly friendly friendly yeah yes and
it does not dissuade Mr Roosevelt
correct correct roll the tape
stop
Kyle bows out into the road goes back
into the carsource lot with him meaning
Mr Rosenbach model correct correct
where's Mr zaminski in this he's on the
sidewalk it's going to be just north of
the blue circle and that's going to be
going right from left to right on that
screen no the other direction to the
right of the blue circle on that screen
okay
so right here no to the right of the
blue stripe yes exactly
[Applause]
exactly behind
the side of Mr Rosemount
yes okay
stop
this is Mr McGuinness
yes
this is Mr Mrs zaminski yes
she's very identifiable because she's
got a big backpack on her back yes
continue
stop
this does not depict
shot correct
I think it appears to be just before
okay
continue
you don't see the flash of Mr saminski's
gun in the thermal correctly
but we know from other videos there's
one a sound and two will flash yes in
multiple videos yes
Mr zaminski didn't come forward and
complain about my clients behavior that
day correct correct he didn't come
forward and complain and say that I had
to shoot him to scare him or something
like that correct he did not come
forward correct
and after my client
shoots Joseph Rosenbaum three times it's
76 hundredths of us excuse me four times
four shots in 76 hundredths of a second
the zaminski's when that shooting is
going on they don't run away they don't
hide it was 76 tenths of the second 76
tenths yes okay thank you for correcting
me the zaminski is 76 tenths
7.6 seconds that's weird right you stay
right there and they start yelling Mr
zaminski still has a gun out
and this is some instruments
get him things like that about Kyle
correct correct like it sounds fast but
there are multiple people closing in on
Kyle okay and that's okay I apologize Mr
Rittenhouse and that's closing in on
them at the car Source parking line
correct
it appears that at the car source that
people are coming towards uh
Mr Rosenbaum
and yes there's people that are shouting
in the direction of Mr Rittenhouse
let's say it's it's more clear once he
starts running Northbound that there are
people following him okay but
all right guys I hate to do this at such
a key time but I am at a hard out I've
got to go I've got a uh a thing I've got
to do so this is the court TV feed for
people who want to continue watching
um I'm gonna be back with more coverage
tomorrow I'm just at the end of my time
I allotted a couple hours for today all
right guys so um the feeds continue I've
gotta run we will see everybody tomorrow